voilà une arrestation bonne et due forme
un bloc à l'avant bras
c'est bloqué c'est bien bloqué là que tu
aimais trade avant tout par une fille
cool et j'ai dans qu'est ce que tu
attends quoi tomber une banque était
sérieuse ou quoi tomasi glisser là
[Musique]
dit on est obligé d'aller dans un
entrepôt mais comme ça et on dirait un
décor de film
ben voila je le sentais ya pas de réseau
open web 0 bas j'ai fait une petite
angoisse mais ça va mieux ça dit qu'elle
j'ai tout pour l'emploi passe à casting
pour un film à hollywood mec jaloux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a pas tout seul j'ai vu qu'il avait
des grosses cordes
mais gracieux
ce que quelqu un mouchoir ta gueule
montrez-moi votre côté pienaar
[Musique]
alors quelle est la cible mammifères ou
être humain la pire soirée de toutes
mains
bon
non mais
et wahaha bravo à toute l'équipe c'était
super y'avait pas de mons c'était une
mise en scène fait j'ai fait en question
il pas longtemps j'ai pu mais c'était
[ __ ] tu pars tout quel bar tu parles